so we got ourselves an fm
i feel like i played the buffalo before
but apparently i haven't
anyway regardless of whether i played
rafaelo before he's gonna get treated to
the rats
didn't accept the rat which means we
have the
quasi rat or accelerated vat or
whatever the cool kids call it
anyway this i feel like is sort of
the best case scenario you can get in
this opening because
this is i think very much a playable
french type of position
it doesn't mean that i'm better or
anything close to it it just means that
i shouldn't shouldn't complain by any
means
so queen a5 i'm trying to
post some questions early on
uh but i am a bit of a chicken so i
think i'll i'll just
post them and then close them as they
say
after all with the structure that we
have it seems
very reasonable for me to want want a
closed
structure okay bishop h6 is a bit
nasty
explaining the fact that i'm not going
to want a repetition
so what i'll do is i'll repeat once and
then i'll do something else
h6 looks a bit stupid but i
do have the option of playing bishop e7
next
and this should mean that i'm
i'm doing fine just fine
once he has to exchange them on e7
then positionally in the long term i'm
doing
doing okay and even though
my uh active prospects
aren't too too great here my position is
so
so solid that i should be fine and
also his bishop doesn't have
doesn't really have a lot of prospects
here like he would love to have
he would love to have a dark squared
bishop in order to
attack the very squares that is
trying to attack with the queen now
but without that there's no bishops i i
i don't i just don't think it's very
effective
don't really think white is worse but
i'm certainly quite comfortable
um yeah it feels like sooner or later i
should have to open up the queen side
here
so i'll try and uh do
that i'll actually do it sooner rather
than later
a6 that means that oh
why did i think i thought rook c5 was
forced
to protect the pawn but obviously this
is much better
yeah that was a mess that was pretty
pretty unnecessary not to say okay
don't think you should be doing this
sir don't think his position was ready
for that
opening it's hp i would have grabbed the
h file and
i just don't think there are enough
pieces for him to attack with
okay this one i'll grab
i can't say i'm a famous pawn rapper
but i still i still like to grab him
once in a while
uh 98
just trying to to consolidate
blundering a6 obviously
um yeah it was unfortunate
really unfortunate oh knight b7 blunders
to
queen of stacks yeah that was really
really bad
i'll go 96 then
yeah rook p6 i was trying to bait him to
go queen of six there but he didn't
take said bait
okay now i have to both play quicker and
to play better
which is a bit of a tall task
tall task and a big ask
okay we'll push this one forward should
not have allowed uk
seven damn it damn it damn it
that was really stupid
really not very clever at all okay i'll
exchange the queens
we'll have the chance try and reroute
tonight
so i need to play a lot faster
okay try and go for a rook attack here
fork fork please blunder yes
i don't have a chance no i forgot to
take the
i forgot to take the rook
damn it and we have a loss
oops oops that wasn't good
that wasn't good at all how did i forget
to
um to take the rook first
it's just not used to playing fast
i have to say good game by my opponent
though
um played
played fast and avoided
avoided blundering for the most part and
very very solid mostly but
yeah i should um should do
um do better